good afternoon everyone thank you all
for being here thank you ed
and everyone who's contributed to
creating the space for us
my name is kester barrow and i'm an area
director for mcgregor house in
residential life programs here at mit
um i'm both anxious and excited today to
really engage in this conversation this
dialogue with you all
at the beginning of the spring 2016
semester the mit community received an
announcement from president reif sharing
with us a tremendous scientific
discovery
he shared that in collaboration with
caltech caltech and the national science
foundation researchers at mit had
recorded the first direct detection of
gravitational waves he stated i do not
typically write to you to celebrate
individual research achievements no
matter how impressive our community
produces important work all the time
but i urge you to reflect on today's
announcement because it demonstrates on
a grand scale why and how human beings
pursue deep scientific questions and why
it matters
today given president wright's words
please keep these two following
challenges in mind as we engage with
each with each other throughout today's
conversation
i challenge you to pursue deep social
questions
i challenge you to define for yourself
why does understanding these social
issues matter
race and other socially constructed
identities aren't real
they're tools created by the oppressors
to maintain the social norms at the
expense of the oppressed
however
race is a lived experience for us all
that's been part of the fabric of the
usa since the founding of this nation
we cannot negate the harm and the pain
that we that we've all experienced as a
result of this oppressive system
if we truly seek to achieve change and
growth we must embrace the challenge of
acknowledging our history and seeking
change
by embracing these challenges we accept
the shame
we will be tempted to shy away from the
shame some of us will retreat inwards
and attack ourselves based upon that
shame
others will project their shame outwards
and attack others
however please keep this in mind
as a man it is my responsibility to
process my shame around gender if i
truly seek gender equity as a
cisgendered heterosexual male it is my
responsibility to process my shame
around sexuality if i truly seek to
support the movement for equity for the
queer community
members of our community are already
gathering in groups to support each
other in the processing of shared
identities and the emotions that stem
from those conversations
in the coming months this is the hope of
many in this room that these spaces
become a norm at mit
where the purpose isn't to segregate but
to but instead to achieve insight and
foster support and healing
if our aim is to truly pursue change we
must try new strategies because the
current strategies have only taken us
thus far
in closing i'd like to take a moment to
acknowledge the weight of the violence
that's plagued our society over the last
few weeks
alton sterling you matter
philando castile you matter
the five officers who died in dallas you
matter
the 49 souls lost in orlando you matter
the victims of the bombings in turkey
bangladesh and iraq you matter
members of the mit community who don't
feel safe you matter
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you